Do you have any advice for someone who
may be a sexual,
I want to have a husband and children,
but I'm 27 and haven't felt connection
with anyone.
I'm just seeing everyone as friends so
far in life.
Well,
he might want to see a sex therapist
that might help.
Um,
I guess the other thing I would say is,
well,
you know,
it might not be too bad an idea to,
um,
act out what you want perhaps in the
absence of any necessary desire.
Like you know,
what you might be so far have fallen so
far inside yourself.
Then it's very difficult to get out.
Um,
what are the sex therapist would do,
would be,
you know,
once you've written some kind of,
let's say,
friendship that you wanted to move
forward would be to have you guys
practice interacting in an intimate
manner,
stage by stage so that you could get
accustomed to it.
You know,
so you need to explore whether that's
asexuality as you say,
or if it's fear or if it's,
you know,
it might be fear of rejection,
it might be fear of sexuality,
might be that you're slow to warm up and
introverted,
but I think seeing a sex therapist might
not be a bad idea.
We know.
I guess the other thing,
and I say this with some hesitation,
is that if you find someone you liked
that you could be friends with,
I mean,
you could try.
I'm initiating a romantic relationship
and practice it for a couple of months
and see what happens because you know,
maybe you'd warm up across time and
certainly it's certainly,
it's certainly a possibility.
So.